Esta es la única carretera que une la
región de nagorno caravag con Armenia
desde hace tres meses el corredor de la
chin está bloqueado por un grupo de
manifestantes aceríes afirman estar aquí
para protestar contra la minería ilegal
en el enclave poblado en su mayoría por
personas de origen armenio la versión de
erevan es bien distinta estos
manifestantes estarían apoyados por las
autoridades aceríes que de este modo
pondrían en marcha indirectamente una
operación de limpieza étnica el bloqueo
ha provocado importantes carencias en
nagorno
caravagna qué podemos hacer al respecto
por supuesto es difícil no tenemos gas y
se producen cortes de electricidad con
regularidad los ancianos conseguimos
sobrevivir pero lo siento por nuestros
hijos
durante la Guerra de otoño de 2020
azerbaiyán tomó el control de varios
territorios armenios entre ellos varios
alrededor de nagorno caravag
tu negocio entonces un alto el fuego y
se desplegaron tropas rusas en la zona
el mes pasado el tribunal Internacional
de Justicia ordenó a bakú que
garantizará la libre circulación de
bienes y personas a través del corredor
la interrupción del tráfico en el
corredor de la chin impidió que las
personas de origen armenio
hospitalizadas en adorno fueran
trasladadas a centros médicos de Armenia
para recibir tratamiento de urgencia
las pruebas también demuestran que hubo
obstáculos a la importación de productos
de primera necesidad anagorno caravag lo
que provocó escasez de alimentos
medicinas y otros suministros médicos
vitales
sin embargo la petición de Armenia de
ordenar a azerbaiyán que dejara de
organizar manifestaciones y permitiera
el flujo de gas natural al enclave por
su parte las autoridades de bakú niegan
que exista un bloqueo total en el
corredor de la China y que haya una
crisis humanitaria en la región